bonsoir alors quand on m'a proposé de
participer à cette conférence je pensais
vous parler de mon de la manière dont
les paysages de création évoluent au fil
de la vie personnelle de l'artiste et
puis en réfléchissant bien au thème je
me suis dit que aborder avec vous le mon
expérience des chemins de Compostelle
serait peut-être plus
appropriée au final vous verrez que tout
se
rejoint en fait de cette aventure des
chemins de Compostelle il y a deux
métaphores qu'on peut
tirer premièrement
elle est la métaphore de n'importe quel
grand projet dans lequel on se lance par
exemple vous vous avez fait le chix
choix de devenir ingénieur ou peut-être
un autre métier et vous vous êtes
renseigné sur l'école dans laquelle vous
vouliez étudier vous vous êtes inscrit
vous avez fait votre entrée votre
premier pas et puis actuellement vous
êtes en train de suivre votre parcours
étudiantin avec tout ce que ça comporte
comme réussite comme effort comme échec
parfois comme rencontre aussi et puis
dans quelques
temps vous aurez vos examens et je
l'espère pour vous votre diplôme et ce
sera la fin de ce
parcours la deuxème métaphore c'est
celle de nos vies on arrive sur cette
terre on est
et c le premier pas notre premier pas on
a ensuite notre parcours notre
expérience humaine terrestre avec ses
dénivelés
et là encore
des réussites des efforts qu'on doit
faire quand on a des montagnes à gravir
et des efforts à fournir pour atteindre
nos objectifs et des découragements
aussi et puis il y a un jour où on
arrive à la fin de notre aventure et on
disparaît des
paysages alors pour une petite remise en
contexte
historique la première fois qu'une
personne s'est lancée jusqu'en Galice
c'était au 9e siècle en 834
c'était le roi Alphonse I qui est parti
pour reconnaître et rendre hommage aux
reliques de Saint-Jean dit le de
Saint-Jacques pardon dit le majeur qui
était considéré comme l'un des premiers
apôtres du Christ alors il l'a fait à
des fins spirituelles bien évidemment
mais aussi avec une dimension humaine et
politique pour ce qui est de ma
situation personnelle j'ai eu
l'opportunité de partir sur les chemins
en mai 2020 juste après le premier
confinement alors comme pour beaucoup de
personne ma vie était à zéro au point
mort plus de
travail rupture
amoureuse plus aucune créativité plus
aucune envie ni de chanter ni d'écrire
ni de monter aucun projet j'étais ma vie
était complètement
vide plus aucune
attache mais de ce néant
total j'ai ressenti le désir profond de
réaliser un de mes rêves qui était
enfouis en moi depuis plus d'une dizaine
d'années qui était de me lancer sur les
chemins de Compostelle et j'avais une
condition à ce rêve c'était de faire ce
chemin en entier parce qu'il est aussi
possible de faire des portions de une ou
deux semaines chaque année mais pour moi
ce n'était pas une option
envisageable alors du coup coup j'ai
fait ce vœux intérieur qui est devenu
une décision et puis j'ai commencé à
l'extérioriser et à en parler autour de
moi et là je me suis confrontée à des
avis
négatifs qui étaient tous parfaitement
fondé
d'ailleurs premier avis négatif ça
venait de mes amis et de ma
famille ils me connaissent très bien et
c'était donc à juste titre qu'il me
disait tu n'as jamais fait de randonnée
tu n'es pas sportive on va devoir
rappliquer dans une semaine alors
c'était pas très encourageant mais
c'était fort
probable le deuxième avis négatif il
m'est venu des associations de pèlerins
que j'avait contacté pour organiser un
petit peu mon voyage savoir un peu où
j'allais mettre les pieds et là ils
m'ont dit Madame oublié ne partez pas
cette année la plupart des hébergements
pèlerins sont fermés à cause desnmes SAN
vous devriez reporter à l'année
prochaine troisième avis négatif et pas
des moindres c'est venu de mon podologue
que j'avais consulté parce que j'avais
des douleurs très gênantes au pied donc
pour quelqu'un qui part faire un long
chemin comme celui-là c'était quand même
un peu embêtant et le podologue m'a dit
il m'a diagnostiqué un névrome de Morton
et il m'a dit si vous vous obstinez à
partir vous risquez d'être de retour
dans 3
semaines alors j'ai pris tous ces avis
en considération
et je me suis interrogé
moi
profondément et pour moi je savais que
c'était le moment que c'était mon moment
où je pouvais partir donc j'ai cherché
et j'ai trouvé des
solutions pour le problème de
l'hébergement j'ai acheté une tente et
je suis partie en autonomie pour le
problème de de santé j'ai commandé des
semelles orthopédiques auprès de mon
podologue et des très bonnes chaussures
j'ai acheté un sac à dos de bonne
qualité et je suis parti
seulle alors les trois premières
semaines ont été assez rudes en
particulier la première nuit que j'ai
passer seule en camping sauvage c'est la
première fois que je me retrouvais dans
une telle situation
et ça a été absolument terrible parce
qu'elle a cristallisé toutes mes
frayeurs les plus profondes ces frayeurs
V qui touche à la à notre survie en fait
et c'est à ce moment-là que dans ce
moment de vulnérabilité tout leseffet
d'hivers qu'on peut voir à droite à
gauche et tout refond
surface j'ai passé une nuit horrible
déjà je dormais avec un couteau dans la
main et et je me réveillais toutes les
20 minutes à cause de mon du propre
frottement des tissus de mon sac de
couchage quand je me retournais dans la
tente en fait et j'étais persuadée que
c'était quelqu'un qui venait m'agresser
alors qu'en fait c'était mon propre son
en
fait alors le jour
s'estlevé moi aussi j'ai survécu à cette
nuit atroce et en fait j'ai eu une prise
de conscience vraiment
importante je me suis dit
ok né je suis sur cette terre et il y a
une seule chose dont je suis absolument
sûre dè que je vais
mourir mais
à quelle heure de quelle manière j'en ai
absolument aucune idée donc qu'est-ce
que je fais est-ce que j'écoute mes
peurs et que je rentre chez moi et que
je vais mener une existence où je
prendrai jamais aucun risque ou est-ce
que j'affronte mes peurs quitte à
peut-être avoir des problèmes mais
j'essa de vivere mon
rêve alors j'ai choisi la deuxième
option et bien sûr j'ai essayé de faire
en sorte de rester quand même prudente
prudente
pardon alors les 3 semaines qui ont
suivi ont été un peu l'écho de cette
nuit-là j'étais très enfermée dans dans
mon mental
et j'étais obnubilée par le passé par
les erreurs que j'avais commises par le
mal qu'on m'avait fait par les projets
son que j'avais sur le futur et du coup
tout ça me m'enfermait j'arrêtais pas de
ma route parce que je n'étais pas
attentive aux signalisations du chemin
tellement j'étais enfermé dans dans mes
pensées et puis au fil des kilomètres au
fil des jours j'ai commencé à prêter
attention aux éléments du paysage dans
lequel j'évoluais tout a commencé à
prendre son importance les silhouettes
des arbres les vaches die sais combien
il y en a sur les chemins français et
espagnol la fraîche chur quand on rentre
dans un
bosquet la chaleur du soleil sur la peau
la texture du chemin et tout ça m'a
permis de m'anqurer dans l'instant
présent et à partir de ce moment-là j'ai
arrêté de me
perdre alors on peut appliquer ça à
notre vie quotidienne évidemment à être
trop enfermé dans dans nos
conditionnements et dans nos manière de
penser on rate on peut rater beaucoup
d'opportunités et de signes qui nous
parlent
alors j'ai marché comme ça jusqu'à
saint-jeanpierdeeport dans le Pays
Basque et un petit peu avant cette ville
les chemins français se rejoignent il y
en a trois la voie du puit envelet la
voie de visel et la voie de tour et à
saint-jeanpier deeport le pèlerin a un
choix très important à faire soit il
prend le Camino franis qui passe par
l'intérieur de
l'Espagne il prend la voinive Bidasoa à
travers les pyrénée et il rejoint le
Camino del Norte pardon le chemin du
Nord qui longe la côte j'ai choisi la
deuxième option j'ai pris la voif
Bidassoa donc c'était assez dur parce
que c'était dans les pérénées donc il y
avait beaucoup de dénivelés et j'avais
quand même 20 kg sur le dos donc ça a
été assez physique et puis je suis
arrivée à Iron en Espagne et là dès le
premier jour j'ai pu voir un grand
changement au niveau du chemin en fait
je venais de faire la voix de visely qui
est aussi appelé la voix de la solitude
et pendant un mois et demi j'ai
rencontré que quatre pèlerins et là tout
de suite le Camino del Norte qui est
réputé pour sa beauté et aussi pour ses
étapes assez physiques euh qu' est
fréquenté par beaucoup de jeunes
sportifs et de jeunes randonneurs ben là
la fréqu la fréquentation était vraiment
très importante et du coup j ai tout de
suite vu une comparaison avec nos vies
sociales
par exemple dès le premier jour j'ai
rencontré une pèlerine avec qui je me
suis très bien entendu on a marché
ensemble deux ou trois jours et puis nos
chemins se sont séparés moi je voulais
rester à Bilbao elle elle voulait
continuer et puis quelques jours plus
tard on s'est retrouvé dans une même
auberge et là en fait il y a un
troisième pèlerin qui s'est greffé à
notre petit duo et on a passé des
journées merveilleuses à cheminer
ensemble il y avait une ambiance très
fraternelle on était très solidaire et
puis encore une fois nos chemins se sont
séparés Juliane abattait plus de 40 km
par jour Valeria elle voulait continuer
sur le chemin du Nord et moi je voulais
bifurquer sur le Camino primitivo et
Valeria je l'ai retrouvé à Saint-Jacques
de Compostelle 3 semaines plus tard
alors j'y ai vraiment vu une image de
nos amitiés d'enfance donc de ces
personnes qu'on côtoie pendant longtemps
et puis on se perd de vue on se retrouve
à l'occasion d'un événement important et
puis voilà ainsi de suite jusque souvent
la fin de nos vies presque c'est des
amitiés qui durent toujours et puis j'ai
aussi eu la chance de
faire une de ces rencontres
fulgurantes de ces personnes qui en
moins d'une heure vous font changer
complètement de regard sur sur la vie
cette rencontre là je l'ai faite un
petit peu avant d'arriver à ob d'au à 7h
du
matin faisait encore nuit il pleuvait
des trombes d'eau des trombes et
j'attendais que la verse passe sous le
préo de l'auberge et pendant que
j'attendais j'étais en train de rédiger
un poste sur facebook j'étais
happé par le virtuel et d'ailleurs ça
m'a donné une bonne leçon parce que
certes les téléphones sont de très bons
outils mais il faut quand même être
vigilant parce que ça peut peut nous
couper vraiment nos intuitions et ça
peut aussi nous faire
manquer peut-être les plus belles
rencontres de nos vies alors du
coup pendant que j'étais en train de
rédiger ce poste il y a un monsieur qui
s'est présenté sous le préo il s'est
installer à côté de moi puis je sentais
qu'il voulait me parler et moi ça
m'agaçait un peu j'étais
concentrée qu'est-ce qu'il me veut et
puis en fait il y a un moment où je me
suis allé pose ton téléphone et écoute
ce qu'il a dire parce que il y a un truc
et en fait monsieur il m'a confié que il
était le seul et unique
rescapé d'un naufrage dans lequel 16 de
ses collègues marins pêcheurs avaient
péri monsieur pr José il est resté 10
heur dans l'eau glacée au large de la
Norvège et quand les sauveteurs l'ont
récupéré et que les médecins l'ont
soigné il lui ont dit monsieur vous
remarcherez jamais c'est terminé
et moi quand j'ai rencontré ce monsieur
il avait fait 110000 km à pied et à vélo
km pourquoi tous ces
kilomètres pour remercier pour tenir sa
parole parce que pendant qu'il était
accroché au cadavre de ses deux
collègues pour pas sombrer au fond de
l'eau et quand il a commencé à sentir
qu'il partait il s'est mis à prier
et il a promis il a dit si vous si vous
me sortez de là si je survis je ferai
tous les pèlerinages du monde pour
remercier et quand je l'ai rencontré il
avait fait quasiment tous les
pèlerinages du monde tout le temps en
passant par la
terre donc cette rencontre m'a
vraiment comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
bouleversé et surtout je vous garantis
que l'étape d'après marcher sous des
trompes d'eau S des éclairs et sous le
tonner c'était une des pires étapes de
mon voyage mais je l'ai faite avec le
sourire jusque là parce
que quand on entend un témoignage comme
ça on se dit que finalement c'est quoi
marcher sous une pluie torrentielle à
côté de voir tous ses collègues de
boulot se noyer devant soi alors rosé ce
cher rosé il m'a
donné plusieurs leçons déjà celle
d'avoir la
foi d'avoir confiance de se sentir et de
se savoir protéger et surtout de
respecter la parole
donnée alors je suis arrivée à
Saint-Jacques de Compostelle
après à peu près 3 mois de marche et
2000 km et c'était terrible je suis
arrivée à Saint-Jacques dans un état en
fait je voulais je voulais plus arrêter
de marcher j'étais presque arrivé à un
point où j'étais parti pour vagabonder
toute ma vie et c'était vous vous
souvenez de la métaphore que j'ai fait
entre chemin de vie et chemin de terre
bah j'avais un peu l'impression d'être
une mourande qui s'accroche à la vie et
qui refuse de finir qui refuse de de
partir alors du coup dans ce moment de
flottement j'ai rajouté TR jours de
marche tu aller jusqu'au cap finisterra
et alors là on a plus le choix parce
qu'on est entouré d'eau il y a plus de
terre le seul chemin qui reste c'est
celui du retour et là-bas j'ai regardé
le coucher de soleil il m'a encore
rappelé que chaque jour et chaque course
avait une fin et puis là il y a un ami
rencontré sur le Camino primitivo qui
m'a dit el camino qui le chemin commence
ici
et oui le chemin il commence quand on
retourne à notre vie quotidienne à notre
vie sidentaire et là on peut appliquer
toutes les leçons et tous les les
enseignements que le chemin nous a
offert alors j'ai pris le bus je suis
rentrée jusqu'à Saint-Jacques et puis
après jusqu'à Auray dans le morbillant
je suis j'ai repris ma
vie et j'étais empli d'une immense
nostalgie mais aussi d'une infinie
gratitude pour avoir pu vivre ce chemin
comme je l'avais souhaité du début à la
fin sans compter que ce chemin m'avait
permis de recommencer à écrire
recommencer à chanter commencé à
composer et puis quelques mois après il
m'a donné l'envie d'écrire un ouvrage
pour parler de lui alors en fait j'ai
bien conscience d'une chose aujourd'hui
c'est que le chemin ilueer à
vivre depuis bientôt 3 ans et c'est lui
qui fait que je suis là devant vous
aujourd'hui et en fait ce dont j'ai
conscience c'est
que tout ça toute cette aventure elle a
a commencé avec un choix et surtout un
pas un seul petit
pas alors voilà je vous souhaite à tous
de trouver votre voix de rentrer en
harmonie avec elle d'écouter un peu les
avis des autres mais pas trop d'être
surtout attentif à vos ressentis
intérieurs avant à vos profonds
ressentis intérieurs et je vous souhaite
aussi de faire des rencontres qui
dureront toute votre vie et puis aussi
de ces rencontres fulgurante qui vous
qui vous donneront le sourire quand vous
serez sous une pluie battante et je vous
souhaite à tous un bon chemin et pour
commencer comme un premier pas une bonne
soirée merci